Transcription: Isabelle Auzias
Relecteur: Tiffany Delaroche
Bonjour.
L'école de 2014, elle est aussi archaïque,
que la médecine de 1750.
(Applaudissements)
L'école n'a pas évolué
depuis plusieurs siècles.
Il y a quelques petites différences.
De mon temps, le tableau était noir,
aujourd'hui il est blanc.
(Rires)
Cet immobilisme de l'école
est aujourd'hui intenable,
pour trois raisons.
La première, c'est que
la guerre des cerveaux a commencé.
Nous avons voulu
une économie de la connaissance.
Nous l'avons !
Et dans une économie de la connaissance,
le seul carburant, c'est le neurone,
l'innovation, le quotient intellectuel.
Dans le monde des algorithmes,
des inégalités incroyables se créent
entre les gens les plus innovants,
les plus doués,
et les gens moins doués.
Un exemple absolument caricatural
résume bien cette situation.
WhatsApp, 55 salariés, 4 ans d'existence,
ça vaut 19 milliards !
Peugeot, plus d'un siècle,
plus de 100 000 salariés,
ça vaut 12 milliards de dollars !
55 petits génies au quotient
intellectuel stratosphérique,
créent plus de valeur économique,
en 4 ans,
que plus de 100 000 salariés dans
une entreprise qui a plus d'un siècle !
La deuxième raison pour laquelle
le statu quo est absolument intenable,
c'est qu'après un départ raté
dans les années soixante,
la robotique et
l'intelligence artificielle
arrivent maintenant vraiment à maturité.
Le neurone a 550 millions d'années.
Le transistor : 60 ans.
Le transistor, le microprocesseur sont
10 millions de fois plus jeunes
que nos neurones.
Dans 40 ans, ou quelque chose comme ça,
le transistor aura dépassé
les capacités du cerveau biologique.
Cette course est perdue.
Entre l'ENIAC, à l'issue de la guerre,
fondé par le génial Turing,
et ses 350 opérations par seconde,
et le TN2 qui fait
33 millions de milliards
d'opérations par seconde
et le milliard de milliards d'opérations
est pour 2019,
il y a un saut extraordinaire.
Cette explosion de
la puissance informatique
permet aujourd'hui l'émergence
d'une robotique de 2ème génération,
dont Google est le leader mondial.
Google qui a racheté 8 des plus belles
entreprises mondiales de robotique.
La Google Car n'est d'ailleurs
qu'une forme particulière de robot.
La Silicon Valley est très optimiste
sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Ray Kurzweil,
l'ingénieur en chef de Google,
nous explique qu'en 2045,
l'intelligence artificielle sera
1 milliard de fois plus puissante
que la réunion de
nos 8 milliards de cerveaux.
Dans 30 ans !
Cela alarme beaucoup de gens.
Bill Gates, qui n'est pas connu
pour être un plaisantin,
estime qu'en 2035,
c'est-à-dire dans 20 ans,
aussi près de nous que
la mort de François Mitterrand,
la moitié des métiers auront été
remplacés par des automates intelligents,
issus de la fusion de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la robotique.
Il cite même les infirmières
dont il prévoit qu'elles seront
remplacées par des automates,
à cette date-là.
Une immense crainte se fait jour.
L'éducation n'est pas adaptée
à permettre à nos enfants de lutter
face aux automates de 2ème génération.
La 3ème raison pour laquelle
le statu quo est impensable à l'école,
c'est que la société de demain
n'acceptera plus les inégalités
de quotient intellectuel !
En moyenne, dans cette salle,
vous avez 130 de quotient intellectuel.
La moyenne française est de 100.
Tout le monde trouve ça normal !
En réalité, c'est intolérable.
Les inégalités de quotient intellectuel
sont la dernière des grandes inégalités,
bien plus que les différences d'argent.
Et les différences intellectuelles sont
la mère de toutes les inégalités.
Entre les gens les plus doués
et les moins doués,
il y a 14 ans de différence
d'espérance de vie,
un écart de revenus de 1 à 15,
d'immenses différences
de catégories sociales,
de diplômes et d'accès à la culture.
En 1750, on acceptait qu'un enfant pauvre
meure dans la rue, sans soins.
Aujourd'hui, c'est intolérable !
Aujourd'hui nous acceptons des inégalités
énormes de capacités intellectuelles.
La société du futur ne les acceptera plus.
En définitive, la révolution des NBIC
c'est-à-dire des nanotechnologies,
biotechnologies, de l'informatique,
et puis de la cognitique
c'est-à-dire l'intelligence artificielle,
les neurosciences et la robotique,
sont en train de bouleverser la société
et de bouleverser la marché du travail.
L'école, telle que
nous la connaissons aujourd'hui,
est absolument disqualifiée
pour permettre à nos enfants
de se battre dans un monde,
où les automates intelligents
seront omniprésents
dans les décennies prochaines.
Que va faire la société ?
Que va décider la société ?
A mon avis, la société va demander
que l'école utilise
toutes les ressources
des technologies NBIC
pour répondre à ces défis.
Demain, l'école utilisera des MOOCs
c'est-à-dire un enseignement online
de deuxième génération,
des technologies de renforcement cérébral,
qu'on appelle le « neuroenhancement ».
Elle acceptera le dopage légal.
Elle acceptera, dans le futur,
des implants intracérébraux
pour nous augmenter.
Et elle acceptera
l'eugénisme intellectuel,
par la sélection des embryons.
Dans le monde de demain,
l'enseignement ne
s'occupera plus du savoir.
L'enseignement s'occupera
du cerveau.
On aura une fusion entre l'éducation
la médecine, l'informatique,
la génétique et les neurosciences.
Et l'enseignant deviendra
un « neuro-hacker »,
Y a encore du travail !
(Rires)
deviendra un « neuro-culteur ».
Ce rapprochement entre l'éducation
et l'école va devenir naturel.
Et l'éducation commencera
avant la naissance.
Le cerveau est un organe extraordinaire,
très plastique.
L'environnement, l'école, la stimulation
sont fondamentales pour développer
notre câblage neuronal et synaptique.
Malheureusement, la part génétique
de nos capacités intellectuelles
est importante.
Un peu plus importante qu'on l'imaginait
il y a quelques années.
Les études récentes comme celle-là
tendent à montrer qu'environ 60%
de nos capacités intellectuelles
sont d'origine génétique,
pendant qu'un gros tiers est lié
à l'influence de la famille,
à l'environnement éducatif
et à l'école.
La Silicon Valley, comme d'habitude,
est en avance dans ce combat,
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire !
Vous avez là le brevet déposé par
23andMe, filiale génomique de Google,
dirigée par l'ex-femme de Sergeï Brin,
le cofondateur de Google,
sur le bébé à la carte et
la sélection génétique des gamètes,
pour faire de plus beaux bébés.
C'est d'autant plus préoccupant
par rapport à nos normes morales,
que la Chine a lancé un grand programme
de séquençage des surdoués,
dirigé par un surdoué,
que vous avez là en photo,
avec le but avoué,
dans la presse internationale,
de se servir de ces résultats pour
augmenter le quotient intellectuel moyen
des Chinois au XXIème siècle.
La société va-t-elle résister
à utiliser ces technologies-là ?
Quand on sait que Bostrom,
l'universitaire anglais,
a démontré qu'avec ces techniques-là,
on pourrait augmenter de 60 points
dans un premier temps,
puis de 120 points dans un deuxième temps,
le quotient intellectuel moyen d'un pays.
Ce qui ferait de Bill Gates
et de Jacques Attali
des gens juste dans la moyenne
dans une première étape,
et déficients intellectuellement
par rapport aux normes de cette époque
dans un deuxième temps !
Bien sûr, tout ça nous semble
très loin de notre vécu.
L'eugénisme, c'est pas pour nous !
Pourtant nous avons déjà mis le doigt
dans l'engrenage eugéniste.
Nous sommes déjà des eugénistes.
Nous sommes déjà dans
une civilisation eugéniste.
Chez nous, ici,
97% des enfants trisomiques
sont dépistés, sont avortés.
Il n'y a qu'un trisomique dépisté sur 30
qui survit au dépistage !
Et aux États-Unis, 28% des Américains
se disent prêts à utiliser
les technologies de scan génétique
pour avoir des bébés plus intelligents.
Que feront les parents des 72% restants ?
Mais la transgression ne s'arrête pas là.
La Silicon Valley est prête à aller
encore plus loin.
Ray Kurzweil toujours,
l'ingénieur en chef de Google,
nous expliquait en mars dernier
à Vancouver, à TED,
qu'en 2035, dans 20 ans, nous aurons
des implants intracérébraux
pour nous connecter plus vite à
la connaissance et être plus intelligents.
Et il nous prévenait
qu'il fallait que nous nous préparions
à avoir une pensée hybride,
mélange de notre cerveau biologique
et de l'intelligence artificielle
connectée à notre cortex.
Ceci crée un bouleversement dans
nos normes morales et politiques.
C'est la fin de l'humanité 1.0,
et l'arrivée, pour reprendre l'expression
du dirigeant de Google,
d'une humanité 2.0.
Tout ceci pourrait mener à
une neuro-dictature,
à un neuro-cauchemar.
C'est pourquoi, si l'école NBIC de demain
utilisera sans doute,
à côté des enseignants,
des ingénieurs éducationnels,
des neuro-scientifiques
et des généticiens,
il faut surtout qu'il y ait
des neuro-éthiciens,
des éthiciens du cerveau,
pour empêcher que la neuro-éducation
ne devienne une neuro-manipulation.
Que faut-il faire ?
Je ne le sais pas !
Que doit-on faire ?
J'ai deux convictions, cependant.
La première, c'est que nous
n'empêcherons pas la Silicon Valley
de fabriquer des machines
plus intelligentes que nous.
Comme le dit Sergeï Brin,
le co-fondateur de Google,
nous ferons des machines
qui raisonnent, qui pensent
et qui font les choses mieux que nous !
Dans ce cadre-là, allons-nous laisser
les gens ayant des capacités cognitives
moyennes ou modestes
complètement dépassés face
aux automates de 2ème génération,
issus de la fusion de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la robotique ?
Je ne crois pas que ce soit possible.
Et ma deuxième conviction,
c'est que si nous décidions
collectivement, politiquement,
dans les années et
les décennies qui viennent,
de bloquer les technologies permettant
de réduire les inégalités
de quotient intellectuel,
nous serions jugés très sévèrement
par les générations futures.
En réalité, nous sommes tous
d'horribles neuro-conservateurs,
qui se satisfont très bien d'intolérables
inégalités de quotient intellectuel.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)